It is very surprising that libraries are now concerned with the Arctic – And then again, not at all.
To me the libraries have always been a place to see for myself what has happened in the cold north.
The best reading experience ever was when Jesper Düring Jørgensen
from Royal Danish Library in Copenhagen showed me the tiny diary,
Jørgen Bjørnlund wrote as he was dying in 1908 during the tragic Denmark Expedition.
I live in the same house the painter Aage Bertelsen had built after the expedition – he survived.
So, to me the library has always been a place I could go to
and get even more information about specific polar expeditions about heroic men
– it was always men –
– but the exceptional and also terrifying and important thing is
that today the library in a completely new way challenges
and takes due account of the issues the Arctic poses
I think it is a scary but very exact expression of the threat we await from the Arctic that libraries,
as cultural institutions are the ones to take up this enormous assignment of communicating information.
There is a climate change denier in The White House, whom, as we know, does not like facts.
However, I trust that the people know better.
I find consolation in knowing that we live in a time where people know better and who know more than ever.
That is actually how it is.
So instead of being overwhelmed by the Arctic coming towards us
– which is happening these years –
we need to trust this knowledge, the planetary consciousness will prevail,
also in regard to the threat of a new and more tremendous climate.
The libraries can most definitely
– as they have always done –
help preserve our cultural heritage, but also proactively fight for culture
to not be transformed and threatened by relentless nature
So Arctic Imagination ... We genuinely need it,
and we are already working on it: Lots of people are already thinking about
what will happen when the Arctic is no longer the same as it used to be, at least in our present consciousness.